y a des fois quelques produits qu'on
attend plus que d'autres et celui ci en
fait partie celui ci c'est un revenant
c'est une marque qui a eu des
difficultés
un peu comme huawei puisque il fait
partie du groupe hawaï est aujourd'hui
plus partie du groupe à où est cette
marque c'est au nord au nord qui arrive
avec son honneur 50 et c'est super
intéressant de pouvoir vous en parle
aujourd'hui de pouvoir le tester de
pouvoir le boxer tout de suite là on va
le boxer je vais couper je vais tester
et je reviendrai ensuite pour vous
donner mon retour comme ça en cendre on
segmente on regarde ça et c'est très
intéressant parce que ça a été une vraie
grosse difficulté lorsque les états unis
ont mis un embargo clairement sur les
produits de huawei et au nord en a fait
les frais aujourd'hui au nord est
indépendant et revient avec un nouveau
produit le honor 50 qui a les services
google
ça c'est que le sigle aussi ça c'est pas
été un au delà du côté péter qui est
sympa qui un petit reflet arc-en-ciel
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est ce ténor
module photo c'est vrai qu'il est quand
même vachement grand c'est une grosse
caméra sur le dessus ici genre du micro
le bouton de volume les boutons pour
l'allumer pour layton un haut parleur
tiroirs de cartes sim petit micro de la
recharge en usb c'est ici rien du tout à
l'intérieur de la boîte de courir le
tiroir de quartier une toute petite
coque ok un gros bloc de charge à ces
deux là honorent super charge max 66
watts à sam à tartiner un max pour vous
le recharger rapidement ok on verra ça
également des écouteurs et un câble on
usb usb pour recharger très rapidement
donc ça c'est toute la partie n boxing
voyez c'est rapide petit ibra sion au
nord pour un bail android je rêvais déjà
très court la partie n boxing maintenant
je vais le tester je m'amuse avec je
donne mon retour un peu plus tard alors
un peu plus tard pour moi pour vous ce
sera le temps d'un ko maintenant je peux
vous dire ce que je pense et vous donner
mon retour sur ceux au nord cinq enclos
nord 50 il est bien sûr plein de points
il y pas parfait mais il fait des choses
qui sont vraiment intéressante au niveau
regarde sans son premier point qui est
super intéressant c'est le poisson
smartphones qui est très léger il fait à
peine 175 grammes ce qui fait que
lorsque vous le tenez comme ça et que
vous êtes en train de jouer à des jeux
c'est extrêmement pratique le capteur
d'empreinte situé sous l'écran
déverrouille rapidement d'un design peut
être sympa lors il ya plusieurs couleurs
ici je vais avoir le frob cristal il
existe également au nord code en vert
émeraude et en noir alors ça vous les
trouverez sur le site de honor et je
vous mets tous les liens en bas dans la
description 6 un smartphone qui vous
intéresse et en termes de prise en main
il si très agréable ce qui est aussi
super c'est son écran incurvé alors
incurvé à 75° époque qui est important
c'est que le curve evans pose absolument
aucun problème regarder ça va pas venir
bouger changer de page donc ça c'est
vraiment hyper bien optimisé très
agréable d'un très grand écran de 6,57
poussée du hall est assez super bien on
est sur un taux de rafraîchissement de
120 hertz alors le truc que je veux dire
un petit peu reproché je trouve très
compliqué à comprendre ce n'est pas ici
monsieur heureux c'est ici dans un
affichage et luminosité c'est noté ici
fréquence de rafraîchissement de l'écran
et vous avez plusieurs modes le mode
dynamique sur lequel je suis tout de
suite donc on va venir changer
dynamiquement élevé et standard alors
standard je comprends bien parce que
c'est du 60 hertz est uniquement de 60
hertz ok mais j'ai un peu de mal à
comprendre la différence entre dynamique
est élevé dynamique ses équilibres rendu
visuel autonomie avec une fréquence
d'actualisation maximum de 120 hertz
hockey et élever ses effets visuels très
fluide avec une fréquence
d'actualisation allant jusqu'à 120 hertz
énergivores je vois que sur dynamique
jusqu'à 120 hertz là je vois que c'est
quand même au full full mais pour autant
je vais jusqu'à 120 hertz donc je parle
de combien de 90 à 120 et la de 60 à 120
ou pas j'en sais rien c'est très mal
précisé et ça d'un point de vue logiciel
c'est pas fou fou c'est un peu dommage
une fois qu'on a râlé un peu sur ce
point là eh bien on peut venir moduler
sa température des couleurs on est en
vive par défaut pourrait bien changer
rendre un peu plus chaud un peu plus
froid moi je vous conseille un poil plus
chaud même si je voulais pas me ici
alors après il ya un autre mode qui est
assez sympa vous venez vous mettre
directement là ils vous aident en
confort des yeux vous le mettez au plus
bas et vous l'actionner ça vient casser
un peu le côté blanc ça vient le
réchauffé un petit peu ça ira très bien
pour lire également le programme et si
vous le pousser à fond c'est pas beau
mettez le en bas et à prévenir le
moduler en fonction de vous de votre
fatigue oculaire et de votre vision donc
ça c'est pas mal il ya plein de petites
options d'un point de vue logiciel c'est
magic 84.2 qui est basé sur android 11
c'est pas à l'expérience la plus folle
d'un point de vue logiciel mais c'est
assez clair assez lisible et dans
l'ensemble ça fera très très bien le
boulot vous avez votre menu sur le
dessus vous y retrouvez vos différentes
options on comprend globalement très
très bien on peut passer en mode sombre
si on le veut bref on avoir tout ce
qu'il nous faut issue dans les deux se
fera relativement bien le boulot un
écran qui est certifié 100 % dci p3 et
un taux d'échantillonnage tactile et ça
c'est bien pour lui et me de 300 m ce
qui fait que lorsque je viens jouer à
des jeux et bien ça sera très très bien
le taf et ça sera supra supra supra
supra agréable donc d'un point de vue
gaming ici on a smartphones qui
totalement optimisé qui fera très très
bien le boulot maintenant il ya un point
que je voudrais lui reprocher ici c'est
toute l'expérience audio que je trouve
pas complètement folle c'est à dire que
lorsque vous allez venir pousser le
volume est bien les haut parleurs ont
tendance à saturer tout ce que j'ai à
vous recommander ici et bien c'est
d'utiliser le bluetooth bluetooth 5.2 on
peut y avait plein de collègues qui vont
bien vous et du sbc à celle d'acs a pété
xf et xj bref vous avez de quoi faire
pour venir connecter en bluetooth et
profiter de la meilleure expérience
audio alors je précise ici vous n'avez
absolument aucune prise jack un donc ne
cherchait pas à brancher en prise direct
vous pouvez lire branche est bien
évidemment en usb c'est ici des
écouteurs mais est-ce que je vais
recommander ça va être le bluetooth
telles quand on se pose la question d'un
smartphone on dit souvent qu est ce que
je vais venir en faire alors bien
évidemment de la photo un écran ya
dernière bref mais en tout cas ce qui
est bien ici c'est qu'on est ce qu'il
faut en terme de performance snapdragon
778 djebbour gaming donc ça smartphones
qui est très cool pour venir jouer vous
avez en plus soit 6 soit 8 gigas de ram
soit 128 soit 256 go de stockage en fait
très rare chanson par package 8 256 628
donc vous aurez dans tous les cas ce qui
conviendra ici c'est un processeur de
qualcomm qui a été gravée en 6
nanomètres au delà du côté technique un
petit peu rébarbatif ça marche bien ça
conviendra parfaitement même pas
retourner tous les jeudis plextor mais
quasiment sauf peut-être les plus
exigeants mais dans l'idée du gaming
vous avez vraiment de quoi faire et si
vous aurez de quoi vous amuser attention
ici vous n'avez pas une extension de
cartes mémoire donc c'est soit 128 soit
256 mais pas plus et ce qui est cool et
si vous avez la recherche très rapide
bah oui forcément plus investi h marc
bloch de charges payées à libé 66 watts
je voulais déjà montré leur lot de boxes
permet de recharger très rapidement 2-0
à 70% seulement 22 minutes ça va très
vite c'est ce côté rassurant c'est pour
ça qu'aujourd'hui on va moins venir se
poser la question de l'autonomie mais
surtout du temps de recharge puisque le
matin vous vous dites pas que ça il
n'est pas chargé les décharges et vos
branchez vous prenez une douche vous
revenez il est quasiment chargé vous
êtes parti pour la journée donc sa côte
est qui est extrêmement rassurant tout
en sachant qu'ici quand même dans une
batterie de 4300 millions par heure on a
quand même de quoi faire la
configuration niveau de la photo est
aussi assez intéressante parce que vous
avez des grands standards un grand-angle
ses standards un ultra grand-angle
hockey et dans cette gamme de prix
autant de tares et dans quelques
instants eh bien on retrouve souvent
avec de la macro il ya un mode portrait
c'est exactement ce que nous a faits au
nord ici on s'en fout un peu d'avoir de
la macro avec un capteur 2 mégapixels
une brève 2.4 on s'en fou d'avoir un
mode portrait pareil 2 mégapixels f 2.4
ça c'est vraiment histoire se marrer
sont rajoutés des caméras c'est du
marketing ce qui nous intéresse
réellement ici c'est votre capteur
principal c'est votre grand angle ouais
il est intéressant sans 8 mégapixels or
qu'est ce que fera ce sont 8 mégapixels
et bien l'idée du trio mégapixels ces
prêts d'avoir à plein de pixels et
devenir le zoom est dans ma photo à fond
on peut le faire si on veut mais c'est
plus l'idée d'avoir dû 9 pixels en eau
qui l'avenir servir déjà pour améliorer
les conditions que vous n'avez pas
beaucoup de lumière ou pour la photo nue
ça va vraiment venir améliorer permettra
également d'améliorer aussi un peu au
niveau du détail mais c'est surtout
saliver plus qu'à les faire des photos
en soit 8 mégapixels parce que vous avez
des smartphones qui sont très très bon
et très côté très connu et qui pourtant
font des photos en 12 mégapixels en tout
cas ici ils ont fait le choix de mettre
1 108 mégapixels qui sera à la renforts
je dirais plus qu'autre chose et
notamment au niveau de la photo nuit
mais ça on le regarde en quelques
instants dans le point négatif que je
veux vraiment voir ici et je vous dis
tout de suite que vous n'avez absolument
aucune stabilisation ce qui fait que si
vous êtes comme moi que vous avez les
mains qui sucrer les fraises et bien ça
va vous aider donc pour tous qui vaille
photos de nuit c'est pas au fond il faut
un pied pour tout ce qu'ils veulent
vidéo c'est pas ouf il faut un pied mais
au-delà de ça on peut quand même faire
des choses assez rigolote avec tout en
sachant qu'à la bande vous avez
également une caméra de sa fille de 30 2
mégapixels qui fera le taf c'est sympa
design qu'ils ont fait au niveau de la
partie photo alors en hausse
effectivement le grand angle ultra grand
angle est située juste là on va avoir la
macro et la caméra bouquet qui est situé
juste la voix la petite caméra de cette
fille est planqué ici dans la bulle côté
photo le résultat vous allez voir son
capteur principal est honnête ça
marchera bien ça sera correct ne sera
pas le tout le plus fou c'est pas le
photophone de l'année mais pour sortir
de belles photos sur votre capteur
principal sera très bien sur l'ultra
grand temps que c'est beaucoup plus
apprécié vous le voyez notamment solaire
d'ici l'indécent compact grand angle et
l'ultra grand temps que c'est beaucoup
plus apprécié c'est pas terrible la
saturation également moins bonnes donc
on peut faire des choses sur lui trois
ans mais voilà vraiment il faut vraiment
avoir envie et avoir besoin comme on est
sur un grand capteur de 8 mégapixels on
vient soumet en x 2 on vient et zoomer
dans l'image en réalité et ça
fonctionnera sur 1 x 2 on peut monter
jusqu'à 1 x 10 mais je vous le
recommande pas parce que le faut dit
c'est pas beau l'aj auxerre un point
sera saturée sur l'herbe devant mais
rien de bien grave et vu ce qu'on peut
retrouver sur l'ensemble du marché saint
pascal problème après pour tout le reste
est vraiment la même chose l'ultra grand
angle est pas beau une fois de hockey au
delà de ça
comblé caméra de cellfish j'aime bien ça
fait le taf c'est bien évidemment moins
saturé que ce qu'on va voir son capteur
principal de 100 8 mégapixels qui reste
quand même le meilleur hélas grosses
références sur ce modèle là mais malgré
tout ça ira très bien je trouve ça
plutôt pas mal et très honnête on
continue ici grand-angle ultra grand
temps dont vous avez compris un petit
peu l'idée la macro mais toujours pas
fan sur du 2 mégapixels on oublie on
peut voir des choses bien évidemment de
près à 4 cm mais le résultat est à la
hauteur la saturation n'est pas là le
détail et pas d'un go personnellement
moi j'aime pas du tout et comme vous
n'avez aucune stabilisation optique sur
la photo de nuit et bien c'est laborieux
puisqu'il faut une exposition longue
donc si vous le tenez à la main et qu en
plus comme moi bien vous tremblez c'est
le bazar regardez là non plus la gelée
calé sur un banc et une fois que vous le
callet que vous le posez sur un trépied
c'est pas mal c'est pas mal sauf sur les
lumières où il va avoir un peu de mal
mais ça ne paraît pas surprenant vu le
smartphone et on peut faire des choses
un petit peu rigolote et au niveau de la
vidéo pourrait venir filmer sur quatre
cas à 30 images par seconde mais ce
qu'on vous recommande ici c'est le full
hd 1080p vous avez acheté entre 30 ou 60
images par seconde pour rester au full
hd cherchait pas à monter au dessus
servira pas à grand chose et c'est
surtout un smartphone ici qu'on va venir
utiliser en vidéo pour des réseaux
sociaux c'est le gros focus qui fait ici
au nord c'était à une époque la marque
jeune de huawei aujourd'hui ils n'ont
plus rien à voir avec huawei mais il
reste toujours une marque jeune on va
venir utiliser ce smartphone pour venir
faire des vidéos pour les réseaux
sociaux et on pense ici surtout à tik
tok parce que vous avez vraiment une
optimisation logiciel pour venir faire
du tic toc est clairement oui on sent un
test vidéo sur la caméra arrière
uniquement sur la caméra riez alors je
teste il ya différentes luminosité il
fait beau il fait chaud ici ok ça marche
voilà le test caméra arrière maintenant
on va passer des tests caméra avant
alors regardez là je peux tendre membres
à l'affût sur un plan large je me
rapproche et la g1 planches mue en
voisin donc là je suis sur un angle un
peu standard c'est très très proches
quand même hein et si je me mets en
large pour venir prendre des photos avec
des amis lorsque vous le tenez à la main
c'est pas très pratique mieux vaut avoir
comme moi une petite perche là je suis
en voisin je peux passer en x 0,5
l'armée emploie 2 donc la vente des sacs
à dos et percé avant plus ma caméra
arrière alors là je suis en voisin sur
la caméra arrière vous le voyez là et je
peux venir changer je peux venir zoomer
dans l'image jusqu'en fois ci ce bon
c'est pas ouf
vous arrivez en face ici une fois de
plus vous n'avez pas stabilisation donc
c'est pas terrible mais voyez on peut
faire cette idée comme ça duo on va
finir par exemple faire une interview
vous allez avoir quelqu'un d'un coup tu
es quelqu'un de l'autre côté vous avez
aussi des incrustations et ont pu
s'essayer vous avez bien évidemment du
nfc du wifi si ça va vite sa tartine et
puis vous avez une double carte sim et
ça ce matin qui coûte des forfaits
628 les tarifs sont marquées d'un jeu
l'elysée débarquer parker 449 euros 90
on est à 450 euros et la version 8 256 4
199 90 je vérifie c'est bien ça on voit
qu'en termes de positionnement on est
dans le haut de gamme du milieu de gamme
n'oublions pas que au nord est une
marque qui s'adresse aux jeunes les
jeunes ne vont pas m me 2000 euros 900
ou 800 euros dans un smartphone pour la
plupart en tout cas c'est la raison pour
laquelle les tarifs semblent assez
modérée bien que ça fasse quand même
déjà beaucoup d'argent à 450 est
quasiment 500 euros donc moi je trouve
que la propre au café au nord là dessus
est intéressante il ya un gros focus qui
est fait sur le gaming la photo va être
intéressant sur votre capteur principal
ou pour tout ce qui va être
divertissement séries films gaming les
usages principaux qu'on retrouve chez la
vieille génial michel comme on aime bien
liens dans le monde des marques et bien
vous aurez ce qu'on viendra ici pour
venir visionner du contenu sur les
réseaux sociaux c'est parfait pour venir
créer du contenu sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est pas mal aussi c'est pas parfait
sur le capteur principal et sur la vidéo
on arrive à sortir quelques petites
choses mais il va pas faire des miracles
et syphon à part conscience donc ce
smartphone le honor 50 je trouve
intéressant et surtout ce qui
m'intéresse c'est de voir le grand
retour de au nord dans les gms les
google mobaye série 6 on verra ce que ça
donne sur les prochains modèles qui
arriveront verra de quelle manière honor
va venir moduler sa gamme qu'est-ce
qu'ils vont venir nous proposer on se
reverra ça et bien évidemment pour le
savoir vous invite à venir vous abonner
petit bouton rouge la cloche vous
connaissez l'histoire d'ici là portez
vous bien des bisous si vous avez
questions suggestions tout ça c'est
juste en bas par le commentaire des
bisous pour les soins de vous
[Musique]